and i learned that uh
it makes a difference this was the
diving board area
and i was one of the guards
and they weren't allowed it was a three
meter board and you fell off sideways
you landed on the damn the darn cement
over there
and corn pop was a bad dude
and he ran a bunch of bad boys
and i did yeah he and back in those days
the shot things have changed and by the
way you know i sit on the stand
and it get hot i got a lot of i got
hairy legs that turned that that that
that that that turn uh um blonde in the
sun
and the kids used to come up and reach
in the pool and rub my leg down
so it was straight and then watched the
hair
come back up again
they'd look at it so i learned about
roaches i learned about kids jumping on
my lap
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap
daddy i'm scared
hello
that man
is apparently the president of the
united states and on today's episode of
the reuben report we will be doing a
dissection
of the nonsense over the last couple
days the crazy statements that he has
made the misremembering
the media cover-ups the complete
collapse of any belief that this guy is
in charge that's what's going on i'm
dave rubin it's march 29th 2022 we're
live streaming on rumble blaze tv and on
youtube and uh yeah you know yesterday
we mostly covered
the oscars smack and i said it on the
show yesterday and i did see that a lot
of you agreed with me like i just don't
know that it was real i don't know that
it was real but what a perfect
distraction it was
from the disaster the abject disaster
that joe biden was over the weekend with
a couple speeches and press conferences
it's just extraordinary so that's what
we're going to be doing today and we've
got we've got some great videos for you
today like strap yourself in
get yourself your coffee or your tequila
whatever you need
because we got a big one for you today a
quick reminder guys don't burn this
country comes out on april 12th you can
get your copy right now at daverubin.com
book that is where all the links are so
you can get it from barnes noble you can
get it from amazon or your local
bookstore etc etc and i'm going on tour
i'm going to be out there with the
people as you know it starts on april
18th in orlando we have a big guest that
i think i can announce tomorrow i think
so i'm working on it people please
there's been some scheduling stuff i
think it's going to happen april 18th in
orlando is where we kick this thing off
then april 19th in west palm beach with
donald trump jr april 20th in clearwater
florida with benny johnson from turning
point april 21st with andrew clavin from
the daily wire april 22nd with the
incredibly
curious michael malus in atlanta georgia
april 23rd janmi park
who's just an extraordinary human being
in chicago april 24th my man glenn beck
in dallas april 25th megan mccain in
washington dc in the heart of the swamp
april 26th we're in west nyack with
megyn kelly may 11th in brea california
with dennis prager may 12th larry elder
in oxnard california may 15th san jose
will announce the guest on that one i
hope we can do it by tomorrow may 16th
the next senator from arizona blake
masters and may 18th in denver and i
hopefully we can announce the guest on
that one very shortly too you can go to
davereuben.com
events and i'm looking forward to seeing
you good people and we've got the books
and they look good and they feel good
they got pages and words and stuff
you're gonna dig at people all right
before we get to the big show i want to
talk to you guys real quick about jen
yourself you know how old does your
mirror say you are when you glance in
that mirror ladies and gentlemen you can
delay this question for 5 10 or even 15
years with the new ultra retinol serum
from genius l thanks to geniusel's new
ultra retinol cream see all the skin
healing benefits of retinol and the
hydrating effects of hyaluronic acid
without the harsh irritation look at
that lady geniusel's retinol alternative
cream uses clinical concentrations of a
natural alternative to correct red
inflamed skin visibly reduce wrinkles
and even out skin tone made for
sensitive skin it's effective hydration
for all skin types and perfect for both
men and women if there's a difference
between men and women i don't want to
get booted from youtube this incredibly
powerful anti-wrinkle treatment is
packed with a blend of natural
ingredients that give your skin all the
benefits of retinol without any of the
unwarranted
unwanted irritation go to januselle.com
dave now for up to fifty percent off the
brand new ultra retinol cream you'll be
amazed with the results or get your
money back you'll also get jenny sells
immediate effects for results in 12
hours or less absolutely free with your
order that's an eight nine dollar value
go to genyasel.com dave that's
g-e-n-u-c-e-l
dot com slash dave free express shipping
free returns exquisite customer service
januselle.com
dave and now back to me okay
joe biden is the elderly man pretending
to be president i don't think that
anyone who has their head on straight
really thinks that he is in charge that
he is really making the decisions we've
all seen the videos where he often says
oh they don't want me talking about this
or they don't want me taking any other
questions and it's like who is they i
don't know is it the obama people is it
the lizard people i have no idea but
someone is in charge of joe biden
he is too old and too confused and too
muddled and too compromised to honestly
be in charge of anything at this point
well now we've got this russia ukraine
war remember they ushered that thing
right in as we closed up the first
season of kobit we'll be bringing back
the second season in a couple months i
think right before the election um well
we have this russia ukraine situation
and the administration the messaging
from this administration has been all
over the place all over the place
sanctions work sanctions don't work
we're not arming people we are arming
people we like a no-fly zone we hate a
no-fly zone uh we're gonna get rid of
putin we're not gonna get rid of putin
it's just been a disaster well here is
joe biden in poland over the weekend
this was the huge story over the weekend
that got completely side
railed because will smith smacked chris
rock but here is joe biden basically
calling for regime change
in russia
we will have a different future a
brighter future rooted in democracy and
principles hope and light
of decency and dignity of freedom and
possibilities
for god's sake this man cannot remain
power
god bless you all and may god defend our
freedom and may god protect our truth
thank you for your patience
this man cannot remain in power that
seems like a pretty radical statement to
say that uh the leader of russia cannot
remain in power as you're giving your
big foreign policy speech as you're
giving your big russia ukraine speech to
just slide that in there this guy can't
remain in power that's different than
saying this guy can't invade another
country that's different than saying
this guy can't give weapons to other
people but to say he cannot run his own
country now i suppose we could have a
discussion about that and we all know
how well regime change wars go but he
kind of threw that in there and uh and
then people started freaking out because
there was all sorts of questions was
that a radical shift in policy are we
actually for regime change in russia
well here's a compilation of confusion
for you for god's sake this man cannot
remain power the white house trying to
make clear in the aftermath we're making
very clear in the aftermath he was not
in fact calling for regime change and
you're going to see when you're there
sometimes you've been there you're going
to see you're going to see women
young people standing standing in the
middle of the front of damn tank white
house officials are telling us that
president biden does not intend to send
us troops into ukraine if chemical
weapons were used in ukraine would that
trigger a military spot response from
nato it would trigger a response in kind
the united states has no intention of
using chemical weapons period under any
circumstance
okay so you can see the the messaging
here is all confusing now i do want to
say something as critical as i am of
biden and whoever's in charge and
everything else i don't think that any
administration could just put all their
cards on the table all the time you
can't always tell the bad guys what
you're going to do before you do it
right you need an element of surprise
there was a certain orange man who used
that to his advantage because people
didn't know what he was going to do thus
the world was pretty safe for four years
but we're not allowed to talk about him
anymore whatever his name was
so anyway you can see the sort of
confusion here he says this thing this
man cannot remain in power that the the
implication is he cannot remain in power
in russia that's where he has his power
but then they they're walking it back
and you know they're not really sure no
he didn't really mean that it was
something more broadly about what he can
do in eastern europe but then biden had
a press conference over the weekend and
then he walked back the walking back
do you believe what you said that putin
can't remain in power or do you now
regret saying that because your
government has been trying to walk that
back did your words complicate matters
well you asked three different questions
i'll answer them all number one i'm not
walking anything back
okay so he's not walking it back when he
said this man can't remain in power his
administration though is walking it back
and the media is running cover uh when
he said he that she asked three separate
questions he then forgot what the other
questions were we should have shown the
whole thing it was actually hilarious
like just perfect biden it's just
perfect bite and uh then we've got more
from biden in this press conference it
was it was just an abject
disaster
because it's ridiculous
nobody believes we're gonna take down i
was gonna i was talking about taking
down putin
nobody believes that
nobody believes that you said he cannot
remain in power so what do you mean by
he cannot remain in power do you mean he
can remain in power when you say he
cannot remain in power nobody believes
that do you think maybe there's someone
i don't know in russia do you think
putin has tv or the internet and maybe
he's going ooh
biden just said that warm up the nukes
you get this this is just endless he
says things they backtrack they're
confused the media runs cover uh but
then uh of course he did actually say
that putin shouldn't remain in power
it means that i would hope
i just it was expressing my outrage he
shouldn't remain in power just like you
know bad people shouldn't continue to do
bad things but it doesn't mean we have a
fundamental policy to do anything to
take putin down in any way
oh he shouldn't remain in power we're
not going to do anything about it we're
just going to say bad things and make
him nervous and get him to warm up those
nukes as i just said you see why this is
all such muddled confusion he was just
later he kept saying how he was just
expressing his personal opinion it
wasn't it wasn't a policy position it
wasn't the policy of the united states
government that this man can't remain in
power it was just his own outrage
man can you imagine these these poor
schmucks who work for this guy the
damage control they have to do after all
of this well it's not just that now one
of the things that happens as you guys
know is that the democrats can basically
get away with anything they can pretty
much get away with anything because the
media runs cover for them so if trump
had had any of these sort of gaffes if
trump had said i mean really think about
it for just a second if trump had said
uh that this man putin cannot remain in
power the front page of every single
newspaper would say that donald trump is
leading us into world war iii that we
are about to have nukes dropped on our
major cities the world is going to come
to an end etc etc but instead they
basically even though he muddles it and
confuses it he says i didn't say it then
he repeats it they kind of run cover for
him
and nobody runs cover like a good anchor
over at cnn here is don
lemon i'm gonna say
my interpretation of this as i said over
the weekend right after the president
said it being here in the region in
ukraine the president is saying exactly
what most of the world feels about
vladimir putin now he did not in that
speech say that vladimir putin should be
removed or we're going to take him out
of power he said this man should not
remain in power
you see these ridiculous semantic aims
now first off don lemon pretends he's a
journalist he often says he's a
journalist and i want to be very clear i
often say it i am not a journalist i am
a guy
who sits in a room with a couple other
people and in the morning i try to think
about what i want to talk about and i
tell you the best
uh stuff i can tell you right i try to
analyze things the best possible they
translate some of the nonsense and then
hopefully you listen and then you go
about your daily life don lemon pretends
he's a journalist would be which would
be an impartial arbiter of the truth and
he would present it to you and walk away
but as he just said there he's analyzing
what the president said so he's the
implication is even though he said this
man cannot remain in power he didn't
really mean this man can't remain in
power he just sort of said that but
that's not the thing that he meant
and also the implication also that that
no one would believe that which is also
what bite is no one would believe that i
said the thing that i just said
they're gaslighting all of us at all
times but you're not going to believe
this
another guy on cnn this jake tapper and
he's just a democrat activist who you
know he's an anchor but okay so be it he
sort of almost kinda gets it the way he
asks this question maybe a little
caitlyn president biden suggested that
no one
could have interpreted his remarks as
calling for regime change
of course jake many people raised that
question of whether or not that is what
he was advocating for at the end of the
speech but today he says he is not
walking back his statement that
president putin cannot remain in power
but jake he also says he is not stating
a new policy from the united states
government
as you can see i've put on my news
anchor glasses so that i can analyze
that clip properly now
you got the don lemon over there saying
no no that's not what he said nobody
believes that's what he said then jake
tapper actually asked a somewhat proper
question maybe it's because of the
glasses which is hey maybe some people
kind of took it the wrong way you see
what's going on here we got we got a
problem but the endless chaos absolutely
continues over the last couple days like
it's seriously
this is banana's level
stuff did you ever see the woody allen
movie bananas we're entering into the
bananas level of all of this uh and even
obama
era people uh leon panetta who was the
defense secretary under barack obama uh
he even thinks that joe biden is causing
some confusion and that might be a bit
of a problem at this point in the game
you've really got to keep your messages
very simple and very direct and i think
this created some confusion
that wasn't helpful
yes i mean president macron has said as
much this has created i think more than
confusion in terms of the tension that
it has for people trying to negotiate
with putin
you know shit's bad when cnn is starting
to make a little bit of sense and
they're bringing on people to actually
say something honest because they want
by default position they want to run
cover that is the the nature of the
network so when they're actually asking
the right questions jake tapper you ask
the right question
when they are actually bringing on a
former defense secretary from obama who
joe biden may not remember it but joe
biden was his number two guy he was the
vp
and he's saying this is causing
confusion then there's a real problem in
the country well if you think all of
this nonsense wasn't crazy enough joe
biden then went and talked to our 82nd
airborne talked to some troops and he
told them that they're going to ukraine
and you're going to see when you're
there and if sometimes you've been there
you're going to see you're going to see
women
young people standing standing in the
middle of the front of damn tank
just saying i'm not leaving
i'm holding my ground
they're incredible
he's literally telling our troops those
are our troops
right he's the commander-in-chief those
are our troops that are sitting in front
of him he's telling them what they're
going to see in ukraine but we're
constantly told they're not going to
ukraine we're not doing anything what do
you think we're nuts we want world war
iii he's telling them what they're about
to see
in ukraine i don't know how he could do
this this is rather remarkable
then he got into it with fox news's
peter ducey who is a
true journalist that we again we really
have we tried to get him on the show i
think we keep we keep yeah we got to try
we've got to get this guy on the show i
don't know that he does interviews that
but he's he's just doing a bang-up job
of holding this administration to
something like there's one guy trying to
do it uh and here he is going after
biden and biden once again saying he
didn't say the thing that he said and we
all heard him say it are you worried
that other leaders in the world are
going to start to doubt that america is
back if some of these big things that
you
say on the world stage keep getting
walked back what's getting walked back
it made it sound like just in the last
couple days uh it sounded like you told
us troops they were going to ukraine
it sounded like you said it was possible
the u.s would use a chemical weapon and
it sounded like you were calling for
regime change in russia and we know
none of the three occurred
none of the three none of the three mr
president you interpret the language
that way i was talking to the troops
we're talking about helping train the
troops in that are the the ukrainian
troops that are in poland that's with
the context i sat there with those guys
for a couple hours that's what we talked
about
so when you said you're going to see
when you're there you were not intending
i was referring to with
beating with and talking with the uh
ukrainian troops or in poland and when
you said a chemical weapon used by
russia would trigger a response in time
it will trigger a significant response
i'm not going to tell you
why would i tell you you've got to be
silly
the world wants to know the world wants
to know a lot of things i'm not telling
them what the response would be then
russia knows the response
okay so he did and i try to give him
credit when he's roughly
coherent and everything else at the end
there it's he said what i just said
earlier which is that you don't just
tell the enemy what you're gonna do when
you're in war you don't just like just
put it all out there guys if you do this
then we do this if this happens then
this happens if this then this you don't
do that so i i will give him some room
to work there now the problem here is
that he partly not only does he just
muddle through all these things and then
say these things and then his people
have to apologize and the media runs
cover but he also kind of doesn't know
what he's saying so peter ducey asked
the right question there especially
about the troops he said to our troops
troops what you are going to see when
you are there now he's backtracking and
saying oh no what i meant was i was
talking to our u.s troops who will be
training ukrainian troops in poland or
something like that and it's like i
don't know maybe that actually is what
he meant
maybe he doesn't even know exactly what
he said
who the hell knows the point is that to
believe any of this at this point is is
tough let's say at best it is tough and
uh if if i haven't laid out a case for
you
now we're going to really slam the door
on this freaking thing because let's
talk about sanctions again you may
remember at the beginning of this whole
war this slow motion war that's going on
where remember for weeks at first they
kept saying putin's going to do it he's
on his way some stuff's going to happen
we'll see what we're going to do and you
know how can we figure out how to deter
him and it's a whole big thing right
we're going to see what we can do and
sanctions and deterrence and blah blah
blah
here's a spectacular compilation
of the confusion over what sanctions do
and why we would drop sanctions on
russia and you tell me
i don't want to color your opinion on
this you tell me if the messaging from
this administration makes any sense
sanctions never deter
you keep talking about that purpose of
the sanctions has always been and
continues to be deterrence the purpose
of the sanctions in the first instance
is to try to deter russia from going to
war the president believes that
sanctions are intended to deter they're
meant to prevent and deter a large-scale
invasion we want them to have a
deterrent effect the sanctions are
designed in the first instance to try to
deter russia for taking further
aggression as well as our efforts to
both try to deter russia through
sanctions if you pull the trigger on
that deterrent well then it doesn't
exist anymore as a deterrent
joe those are all people who work for
you
are they all liars or idiots
sanctions never deter
what would be the purpose of sanctions
then when you when you do sanctions
financial
or in terms of trade or whatever it
might be the idea of sanctions is it's a
non-violently
combative way of getting another country
to do what you want so you're deterring
them
you're trying to change their course of
action
that is the essence of deterrence
deterrence is also hey i've got a big
ass bomb and if you do some [ __ ] i don't
like i'm gonna drop that bomb on you
that's a type of deterrence that's why
for four years we had peace under orange
man because people didn't know what he
was gonna do now we get this crazy
messaging like this is really crazy
messaging i know today's show has not
been the funnest show i've ever done
it's certainly not the funniest but like
this is bananas stuff you have the
president saying that that sanctions
don't deter and then you have his entire
administration saying the absolute
reverse so are they
in dereliction of duty and they don't
listen to him or does he not know what
he's saying or did he go off script
there or what is going on here but the
good people of america
sure they don't know what gender they
are sure they're told that being not
racist is now being racist and all that
stuff
but something seems to be seeping
through because the polling for this
elderly man is really not going well and
they even had to cover it on nbc
with chuck todd this past weekend
by a fairly large 71 to 28 percent
margin americans say they do not have a
lot of confidence in president biden's
ability to respond to this war 57 say we
are already at war with russia or will
be within a year a very pessimistic view
34 disagree what's more 68 would prefer
mr biden make the economy his top
priority compared with just 29 percent
who want him to focus on ending this war
overall president biden's job approval
stands at just 40 percent with 55
percent disapproving this is his worst
showing yet in our polls since he became
president
you know it's bad when corporate media
mainstream media funded by pfizer media
brought to you by the drug companies
media
when they are going man this polling
looks pretty crappy we are in a lot of
trouble here
let me just say this about the war in
general and whether we're at war or not
i mean we're in a proxy war we are in a
proxy war there's been no debate about
this proxy war in congress although
congress wants to you know mitch
mcconnell i wanna we're gonna get we've
gotta arm them and 14.8 billion dollars
we don't have any money for our own
stuff um but i was thinking would it be
a crazy thought
to think that perhaps guys uh we have
our own problems here in this country
that maybe we have problems related to
supply chain and inflation and gas
prices and health care and
foreign policy obviously but that we've
got a whole bunch of stuff that's a
problem here our education system is in
complete collapse we're watching
institutional collapse across the board
in all of our trusted institutions
perhaps we need to focus on that kind of
stuff we've got
hundreds of thousands of people pouring
through the southern border perhaps we
should be thinking about what we could
do there does that make me a putin
puppet
does that make me a russian apologist uh
or does it make me a decent american
who actually thinks that this government
is completely inept and should have very
little to do with our lives and if it
should have very little to do with our
lives it probably shouldn't have that
much to do with ukrainians lives or
russians lives that's not to dismiss
people being killed and displaced and
it's and it's deeply troubling and
disturbing and i look forward to all of
the good democrats welcoming ukrainian
refugees some of them nazis into their
homes you know because that's what good
people would do so i don't think that
anything that i've said here is
unreasonable as i always say it would be
nice if the president of the united
states was capable it would be nice it
would feel great actually you know every
time i show you guys one of those
desantis videos it's like man here's a
guy in charge you know what he thinks
he's basically doing what he says he's
going to do and there's a vision there
and he's fighting he's fighting to keep
people free what is it that joe biden
and this administration are fighting for
i have literally no idea other than to
just keep the charade going right
there's no business like show business
that's where that's where we're at at
this point and the polling is just
it's just an absolute disaster so that's
the silver lining right i always try to
get you the silver lining the silver
lining is this administration's in free
fall the the woman
who is second in command kamal harris
nobody nobody thinks she's even remotely
competent
so perhaps enough of us will vote these
people out when it when the time has
come perhaps enough people especially in
the midterms um
will say hey we got to get rid of the
democrats and the republicans ain't
great but they aren't all completely
insane that would be enough it's not my
words here that are crazy it's their
actions that that really is it ladies
and gentlemen all right let's jump to uh
some comments from the locals community
amy says maybe joe thought he was
looking in a mirror when he said this
man cannot remain in power yes wouldn't
that make more like maybe that's him
blurting out something true you know one
of the things that happens when you
start having these cognitive issues
dementia alzheimer's et cetera et cetera
and i have not diagnosed him i don't
have any information that you don't have
but i do have an ability to watch people
over time and something ain't right
there but one of the things that happens
is people that develop these cognitive
disorders as they get older they start
blurting out the truth because the
sensor part breaks down that's why every
now and again he does his weird whisper
thing because that's another thing that
happens you start dysregulating your
emotions don't feel quite right or you
outburst and yell at somebody
so i think it's quite possible that he
was talking about himself this man and
also remember this we are a year and a
half into this freaking thing
we got two and a half more years of this
embarrassing travesty
like can this hold can this hold i don't
know doesn't seem like it can
uh jj says joe blink twice if you're
being held prisoner i saw it he blinked
yeah it's like
really think about it so he gives these
press conferences right and he's tired
and muddled and you know he walks now
like mr burns and i'm not making fun of
old people i love old people i've always
loved old people when i was 12 years old
and i saw the golden girls for the first
time i thought it was the funniest show
in the history of television and i still
watch it every sunday on hulu okay i
still i i just generally i love the
movie cocoon okay
uh i love old people
i loved my grandparents i like i like
generally being around old people i do
find you can get wisdom from them and
humor and all the stuff right so this is
not mocking him for his age but at the
end of
these press conferences at the end of
these speeches just imagine what's going
on the second
they step behind the curtain and the
shitstorm of lunacy that everyone has to
deal with he said this this this and
this we've already said that this the
other thing that's completely
conflicting with that now we've got to
get our our team out there to spread the
word amongst the mainstream media that
nothing he says makes any sense or
nothing he says is actually what he
means and we have to do the reverse and
thank god we have some people at cnn who
will still run cover for us and
everything else
like it's just the look behind the
curtain guys look behind you don't even
have to see what's behind the curtain
you just have to know that there's a
curtain there sherry says why don't you
say trump's name instead of orange man
risk of youtube cancellation it just
seems kind of funny to me actually
sometimes i say it but i do like saying
orange man because it's like
they they unpersoned him they they
canceled
the most powerful person in the world
big tech managed to cancel donald trump
they did it right in front of our eyes
you know in essence they're canceling
russia right now right they're canceling
you know you can't buy russian vodka in
all of these stores it can't be imported
and they took the russian national team
off the nhl hockey game on playstation i
mean who are you punishing who are you
are you punishing putin are you
punishing vodka importers and exporters
and are you punishing hockey players
that happen to be russian who you know
nothing of their politics uh so i always
say orange man because it's like we
should remember
we should remember that guy it was it
was better than that um so i will mix up
orange man and trump i think people know
who i'm talking about but it's more it's
a sort of subtle reference to we let
them erase this guy and
it's just obvious you don't have to be a
trump supporter
you don't have to be a trump supporter
you don't have to want trump to run
again you don't have to like anything
about trump you really don't but i think
most sane people this would be a good
test why don't we run a little test here
for everyone watching this everyone
watching this has a friend or a family
member that has or had trump derangement
syndrome or just despised the guy or
really believed in joe biden you know
the whole thing whatever it is
why don't everybody everyone watching
this let's do a test throw it in the
comments uh
if you really want me to see it go to
reubenreport.locals.com that's where i
can actually really read the comments
but throw the comments wherever you are
we'll have our guys take a look go to
one of your friends with trump
derangement syndrome go to one of your
friends who voted for joe biden and say
do you think
that things would be this bad
under donald trump
do you think this war that we're not at
would be happening do you think gas
prices would be like this do you think
inflation would be like that do you
think that the afghanistan thing would
have been as big a disaster do you think
the border thing would have been as big
of a death just go through a couple
things most likely they're going to yell
at you they're going to call you racist
and you're a mean bad bad person for
asking questions and saying things that
are true but i i believe in you guys i
believe you can do it i believe you can
ask your friends a question and uh see
what they say about all that uh i've
enjoyed today's show
i think it was solid i think we
wrapped it up nicely guys i want to
remind you you can order don't burn this
country at daverubin.com
book and you will get your book on april
12th on launch day and i promise you
it's good and thoughtful and you're
going to enjoy it and if you go to
daverubin.com
events you can join me on tour i'm
getting out there people back into
america i'm going to see people the vip
tickets are selling out almost at every
venue already we're going to try to add
some more uh i think west palm has
totally sold out on those already
but you can jump in there see what you
can get still and it's going to be fun
different show every night different
guests every night i'll do different
things i'm going to give away t-shirts
maybe more who knows maybe i'll give who
wants my chapstick you want this
chapstick it's possible okay no you
can't have the chapstick no
sorry you can't have the chapstick i've
been told you can't i don't know why why
can't they have the chapstick people
it's it's been on oh covered sorry you
can't have the chapstick well i will
bring a new chapstick
to the show and give it to someone out
there
guys part one of my interview with the
original the one and only wolf of wall
street jordan belfort is up right now on
youtube and on rumble and uh oh and it's
the first interview that we've done here
in my house in person so if you want to
see we did it in my living room and we
it's we shot it really nicely good work
by my guys here
and we're gonna do some more things like
that where we'll shoot things either in
my house or on location you know i do
miss the in-person interview so it was
really fun to to sit down with jordan
and the guy is just a freaking ball of
crazy crazy crazy politically incorrect
energy
and
we've got some other tricks coming up
our sleeve but i'm not going to tease
too much right now and on that note i
think it's time for a cold close to the
show
and uh
whether you saw it at the top or whether
you're just jumped in in the middle of a
show i think you're going to dig this
one
joe biden ladies and gentlemen i learned
a lot
and i learned that
it makes a difference this was the
diving board area
and i was one of the guards and they
weren't allowed it was a three meter
board and you fell off sideways you
landed on the damn the darn cement over
there
and corn pop was a bad dude
and he ran a bunch of bad boys
and i did yeah he and back in those days
the shot things have changed and by the
way you know i sit on the stand
and it gets hot i got a lot of i got
hairy legs that turned that that that
that that turn uh um blonde in the sun
and the kids used to come up and reach
into the pool and rub my leg down
so it was straight and then watch the
hair
come back up again
they'd look at it so i learned about
roaches i learned about kids jumping on
my lap
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap
daddy i'm scared